and welcome to hannity and tonight
biden's presidency it is full out
imploding but apparently no one told joe
biden according to reports the president
has decided to run for re-election in
2024 bragging to barack obama that he's
the only democrat who could actually win
now this brings us to an important issue
has joe biden really lost touch with all
reality it's a serious question question
unfortunately every week we all watch
observe as cognitive abilities they get
worse and worse a new issues and
insights poll found that one-fifth of
americans don't even think joe biden
will make it through his first term only
45 percent think it's very likely that
he will make it all four years this term
and today at a tiny event new hampshire
well joe is in rare form as usual take a
look
maine new hampshire america have gone on
the mend
they're on them they're not on the mend
any longer they're on the move
and we're coming to ought to add our
challenges from position to strand
we're going to hire a full-time
interpreter just to make sure we get it
right unfortunately it gets even worse
just listen how joe biden responded to a
reporter who asked him a question about
america's european allies and the war in
ukraine take a look
what did you discuss with the allies
today about ukraine new hampshire
really i'm here to talk about new
hampshire i
understand all right
we're not going to answer that question
you know think about last week on this
program donald trump was on this program
for 40 minutes the better part of 40
minutes fluent energetic informed
ideas i mean
could joe biden ever do that
now the president only wants to talk
about new hampshire except apparently
when he needs to blame our economic woes
and everything else on vladimir putin
take a look
let's be absolutely clear about why we
have such high prices now there are two
reasons
first was coving and the second big
reason for inflation
is vladimir putin not a joke
not a joke without a joke it's putin
it's covered
he looks tired doesn't he anyway biden
once again making excuses for his own
economic decisions and failures his own
energy decisions and failures he
injected trillions of dollars of cash
into an already hot economy he
restricted all oil and gas drilling and
exploration all over the country we
showed you these charts last week we'll
show you again tonight we already had a
40-year
high of inflation
months before russia invaded ukraine gas
prices were up dramatically long before
russia invaded ukraine joe is just lying
uh just like he lied that he never had a
single discussion with zero experienced
hunter about his farm business dealings
but the big guy we now know had many
discussions and dinners and meetings but
now joe refuses to accept responsibility
for pretty much anything it's always
someone else's fault the buck doesn't
stop with him and it's all out of
control
anyway the buck i guess stops with us
it seems like it never will take he'll
never take any responsibility for
anything but the reality is we have a
president of the united states in an
obvious steep cognitive decline and a
formal law school cheat and plagiarizer
always lacked integrity and that's kind
of like the biden way like father like
son we are now hearing by the way
according to my sources tonight big news
surrounding hunter biden's criminal
investigation is forthcoming this
administration is a disaster on so many
fronts and frankly it's hard to keep
track if that happens to hunter let me
tell you something these emails
implicate his father joe and if you just
switch the last name to trump you know
the media mob would have a very
different reaction and now with biden's
poll numbers cratering to historic lows
nbc new low cbs new low fox news new low
33 percent new low with quinnipiac the
white house has a big plan to turn
things around they want joe biden now to
focus more on
domestic issues really that's the plan
will he finally head down to the
southern border is he going to cut taxes
to ease the burden of inflation will he
unleash domestic production of oil and
gas to reduce prices at the pump uh
spoiler alert he's not going to do any
of these things instead joe will likely
travel to a few cities close to the
white house encourage americans to make
sacrifices all in the name of climate
change and so-called equity programs
he'll push more social spending
proposals which would make inflation
even worse and get this biden's new
economic report mentions the word gender
again gender 127 times
inflation is only mentioned 87 times
explain that to your kids anyway
naturally joe will also vilify his
political opponents smear them as racist
and sexist and of course he'll continue
to blame all of his failures on covet 19
and vladimir putin which is a pretty
weird strategy since biden once vowed to
stand up to vladimir and he promised to
shut down the virus neither of those
things have happened and now not only
did biden utterly fail to shut down the
virus but his administration can't even
get their messaging straight on whether
or not you the american people should be
wearing a mask on a plane or a train
yesterday a federal judge in florida
struck down biden's mask mandate but we
still don't know if the administration
will appeal the ruling at one point
today biden said that wearing a mask was
an individual choice and a few hours
later he demanded everyone continue to
wear their masks clearly leadership is
not exactly something the administration
does well and that's because joe biden
is not a leader he's corrupt he's
cognitively struggling he's a career
politician who is a few decades past his
prime i have no idea if he'll actually
run for reelection but i do know that
almost no one outside of the white house
wants another four years of joe biden
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else